en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre la
unidad de medida llamada gramo ok vamos
a hablar sobre el gramo y el grano es
una unidad para medir la masa ok el
gramo se utiliza para medir la masa
ahora bien tú te preguntarás qué es la
masa y quizás en a lo mejor tu vida
cotidiana habrás oído a personas decir
cosas relacionados con con gramos o
quizás con otro término que se le parece
verdad y a lo mejor bueno no se te
habrás percatado de algunas cosas como
las plumas verdad pensemos a lo mejor en
una pluma y voy a tratar de dibujar una
una pluma key más o menos así
ok no sé quizás es algún ave muy extraña
que tiene un plumaje rosa ok ahí tenemos
una pluma ok entonces a lo mejor con
este tipo de objetos que a lo mejor lo
podemos representar bien a través de una
pluma podrás haber escuchado que la
gente dice que esto no es muy masivo
verdad que quizás esto no es muy masivo
a diferencia por ejemplo de si
tuviéramos no sé una roca muy grande no
sé quizás como las que te encuentras en
alguna montaña que digamos que tenemos
esta roca ok y la gente a lo mejor diría
que este objeto sí que es masivo verdad
esto sí que es masivo entonces este
término masivo pues justamente está
relacionado con la masa verdad esto lo
que nos dice la intuición que nos genera
el concepto de masa es esencialmente
cuánta materia tiene un objeto verdad
está relacionado
con el peso pero no es igual verdad por
ejemplo si viajamos a otro planeta el
peso puede cambiar la masa no cambia en
ningún lado no importa si te encuentras
en la selva en la luna o quizás en otra
galaxia ok por supuesto todo esto lo
estudiarás con mucho más detalle cuando
lleves clases de física en donde te
darán digamos la justificación de por
qué peso y masa no es igual verdad
quizás incluso escucharás en la vida
cotidiana por ejemplo cuando vas al
mercado que da lo mejor una persona
pregunta cuántos gramos pesa no sé una
manzana y lo correcto sería decir
cuántos gramos tiene esta manzana verdad
pero bueno podríamos aceptar
coloquialmente decir cuántos gramos pesa
un objeto verdad sin embargo no es lo
mismo entonces una forma de medir
digamos la masa que tiene un objeto
podría ser por ejemplo sosteniéndolo
verdad porque mientras más masa más más
cantidad de materia tenga uno
pues tiene un mayor peso verdad así que
este este digamos esta forma de medir la
masa no solo está relacionado con el
gramo sino con otro concepto muy
importante que es el kilogramo
el kilogramo y el kilogramo voy a
escribir lo mejor kilo gramo y que no es
otra cosa más que mil gramos son
exactamente 1000 gramos ok
un kilogramo son 1000 gramos y a lo
largo de toda su formación digamos
escolar vaso vas a ocupar muchísimo el
prefijo kilo verdad que esencialmente
siempre nos dice que son mil cosas de lo
que estamos hablando por ejemplo en
kilogramos son 1000 gramos muy bien así
que para que esto no quede solo en la
plática muy muy abstracta digamos vamos
a ver algunos ejemplos para tener idea
de cuántos gramos tienen algunos objetos
ok veamos algunos algunos ejemplos por
ejemplo esto que tenemos por aquí o que
ya y oportunamente puse algunos dibujos
que me parecieron bastante bastante
buenos para tratar de ver cuánto pesan o
cuándo cuántos gramos tienen
algunos objetos por ejemplo este primero
de aquí es un clip verdad y los clips
pesan aproximadamente un gramo y por eso
es que pongo digamos esta onda de aquí
que significa literalmente que algo es
aproximado verdad aquí nos dice que es
aproximadamente un gramo porque porque
puede ser que algunos clips pesen no sé
1.5 gramos o punto 98 gramos pero el
punto es que es cercano a un gramo
entonces si tú quisieras saber más o
menos de qué se trata pues pone un clip
en tu mano verdad y fíjate en que tanto
empuja tu mano hacia el suelo verdad y
te darás cuenta que no es mucho ahora
bien qué pasa si nos saltamos al ejemplo
de un lápiz como la segunda imagen un
lápiz nos dice que tiene una masa
aproximada de 55 gramos verdad eso
quiere decir que la masa de un lápiz es
mucho más grande que la de un clip y de
hecho es más o menos la de cinco clips
verdad
ahora bien qué pasa si por ejemplo nos
saltamos al mundo de los seres vivos y
consideramos un pequeño ratón de campo
un pequeño ratón de campo tiene una masa
aproximada de 20 gramos eso es lo mismo
más o menos que cuatro lápices o que 20
clips si tú pusieras cinco o más bien
cuatro lápices en tu mano tendrías el
mismo peso aproximado de un ratón de
campo muy bien pero podríamos incluso
considerar mamíferos un poco más grandes
como este pequeño gatito recién nacido
que a sus pequeños digamos a su corta
vida puede tener una masa de 200 a 300
gramos muy bien eso sería equivalente a
poner aproximadamente unos 300 clics
juntos o por ejemplo unos 10 ratones
bueno pero qué pasaría si no tuviéramos
digamos centenas de gramos qué pasaría
si ya llega
miles de gramos verdad entonces hablamos
justamente anterior
digamos acá arriba que cuando tenemos
1000 gramos hablamos de kilogramos y por
ejemplo tengo un libro en mi repisa que
es bastante grande y que tiene una masa
de 1000 gramos verdad eso corresponde a
un kilogramo este libro nada más este
libro tiene una masa de aproximadamente
un kilogramo eso es digamos como mil
clips verdad o podrían ser unos 200 200
lápices muy bien sin embargo también
podríamos hablar de los gatos y quizás
antes de hablar de los gatos aquí hay
algo muy importante que hay que notar
aquí los kilogramos los denotamos como
caja mientras que los gramos los
denotamos simplemente como
muy bien esa es la distinción que
tenemos hacer tenemos que hacer perdón
un gato como este que tenemos en esta
imagen tiene aproximadamente de más a
tres kilogramos entre 3 y 5 kilogramos
verdad esos son como tres libros muy
bien de hecho si lo comparamos con con
el pequeño gato recién nacido es diez
veces su masa verdad tendrá quizás un
peso de diez veces lo que tiene este
pequeño gato pero también podríamos
compararlo con la masa de los primates
como este en particular que tenemos aquí
verdad digamos una persona normal o
bueno no ando tal vez no normal sino una
persona tendrá no sé alrededor de 70
kilogramos de masa como este personaje
de aquí verdad y quizás a lo mejor si tú
vives no sé en en un país donde se
utilizan otro tipo de unidades de de
peso pues podrías comparar que un
kilogramo
más o menos son 2.2 libras sin embargo
las libras es una unidad para el peso
mientras que los kilogramos son para la
masa muy bien ahora bien qué tal si nos
vamos aún con un animal mucho más grande
como es una vaca verdad una vaca tiene
una masa de aproximadamente 750
kilogramos y quizás en un primer intento
tú dirías bueno esos son como 750 clips
pero no es cierto porque porque los
kilogramos son 1000 gramos verdad son
1000 gramos eso quiere decir que 750
kilogramos corresponden a 750 mil gramos
es decir necesitaríamos 750 mil clics
para poder equiparar el peso conjunto el
colectivo de todos esos clips con el de
una vaca